[Music]
in the year 1066 7000 Norman infantry
and Knights sailed in warships across
the English Channel their target England
home to more than a million people
theirs was a short voyage with massive
consequences and around the same period
of time other groups of Normans were
setting forth all across Europe going on
adventures that would reverberate
throughout that continents history so
who were these warriors and how did they
leave their mark so far and wide our
story begins over 200 years earlier when
Vikings began to settle on the shores of
northern France as part of a great
Scandinavian exodus across Northern
Europe the French locals called these
invaders Normans named for the direction
they came from eventually Charles the
king of the Franks negotiated peace with
the Viking leader Rollo in 911 granting
him a stretch of land along France's
northern coast that came to be known as
Normandy the Normans proved adaptable to
their newly settled life they married
Frankish women adopted the French
language and soon started converting
from norse paganism to Christianity but
though they adapted they maintained the
warrior tradition and conquering spirit
of their Viking forebears
before long ambitious Norman knights
were looking for new challenges the
Normans best-known achievement was their
conquest of England in 1066 William the
Duke of Normandy disputed the claim of
the new English King Harold Godwinson
soon after landing in England William
and his Knights met Harold's army near
the town of Hastings
the climactic moment in the battle is
immortalized in the 70 meter long Baia
tapestry where an arrow striking Harold
in the eye
seals the Norman victory William
consolidated his gains with a huge
castle building campaign
and a reorganization of English society
he lived up to his nickname William the
Conqueror
through a massive survey known as the
Doomsday Book which recorded the
population and ownership of every piece
of land in England Norman French became
the language of the new royal court
while commoners continued to speak
anglo-saxon over time the two merged to
give us the English we know today though
the divide between lords and peasants
can still be felt in synonym pairs such
as cow and beef by the end of the 12th
century the Normans had further expanded
into Wales Scotland and Ireland
meanwhile independent groups of Norman
knights travelled to the Mediterranean
inspired by tales of pilgrims returning
from Jerusalem there they threw
themselves into a tangled mass of
conflicts among the established powers
all over that region they became highly
prized mercenaries and during one of
these battles they made the first
recorded heavy cavalry charge with
couched Lance's a devastating tactic
that soon became standard in medieval
warfare the Normans were also central to
the First Crusade of 1095 299 a bloody
conflict that reestablished Christian
control in certain parts of the Middle
East but the Normans did more than just
fight
as a result of their victories leaders
like William iron arm and Robert the
crafty secured lands throughout southern
Italy eventually merging them to form
the kingdom of Sicily in 1130 under
roger ii the kingdom became a beacon of
multicultural tolerance in a world torn
apart by religious and civil wars muslim
arab poets and scholars served in the
royal court alongside
byzantine greeks sailors and architects
Arabic remained an official language
along with Latin Greek and norman-french
the world's geographical knowledge was
compiled in the book of Roger whose maps
of the known world would remain the most
accurate available for 300 years and the
churches built in Palermo combined Latin
style architecture Arab ceilings and
Byzantine domes all decorated with
exquisite golden mosaics so if the
Normans were so successful why aren't
they still around in fact this was a key
part of their success not just ruling
the societies they conquered but
becoming part of them although the
Normans eventually disappeared as a
distinct group their contributions
remained and today from the castles and
cathedrals that dot Europe's landscape
to wherever the English language is
spoken the Norman legacy lives on check
out this lesson to learn more about how
the Normans helped shape the English
language
[Music]